foreign
welcome to this interesting video in
JavaScript
the best way to master a language is by
programming in it if you enjoy watching
such Tech videos make sure to subscribe
to our Channel and hit the Bell icon to
never miss an update so what's in store
for you
we'll first create some simple beginner
level projects like how to build a
calculator app
then we'll move on to more advanced apps
like the weather app the tic-tac-toe
game and finally we'll conclude the
session by creating a snake game
application
now I'm sure you're excited to dive deep
into it so let's begin
so decided to basically develop very
interesting project in JavaScript
traditional calculator application
like you have seen earlier some projects
like in tic-tac-toe you talk about
snacking you talk about the quiz
application this time we're going to
introduce you another very interesting
project using this JavaScript HTML CSS
so called calculator application so
let's get started let me try to delete
first those files which we really do not
need it now
uh we delete this all yeah now I'll be
creating a new folder now into the name
call
calculator
and in this calculator app once again we
need some new files which is called
index
Dot ht1
and we also need one more that is called
app Dot
CSS
and another one that is called app dot
Js so these three files required now
first of all I would start with
index.html file where we'll be creating
a template of my code now
let me go and create
I forgot body with me
let's start with the
first
tag here that's called H1
and this H1 we are giving the name
called calculator
so that will be my H1 heading after that
we'll start working the div tag
now within this tip I have to create lot
many classes I may not have lot many CS
classes but we can't give some classes
here so we can say class equal to
container
okay so within this div tag we're going
to create
to organize it
so I'm starting with the table within
this table
TR tag and within this TR tag I need a
TD
now in this 3D I need few things called
call
span equal to 3
another value
here
I want to offer the text box
type equal to
text
okay inputable text ID equal to give the
new core result
that will be the final outcome while
pressing all the different buttons ID
equal to result and
plus equal to
the screen remember I haven't created
two CSS classes but we're giving some
names but later on we can utilize it
while creating those CSS classes
table data is getting closed let's get
started with another TD
now inside this TD we need another text
box
type equal to
text
and here in this input a group text
sorry I would like to better say button
because I'll be having
buttons
okay
input I'm equal to
button value
equal to
C
and one click
equal to I may not have any function
right now but yes I can create a
function but let me give some dummy name
here I'm saying clear
screen
okay so that will be the function we get
called
and after that class
equal to clear
yeah so this is my button tag
after this a TD tag is getting closed
after the daily tag the table rules also
getting closed after the table row
which is getting close we're going to
start working with another table row
okay and in this table view I'm going to
create one more TD
so let's go and create
another TD here and inside is 3D I'll be
having another project we get created
so I'll just say
this is my another button now input
Apple button value equal to
1 on click equal to you call it another
function called display
okay and inside this we're giving the
valuable one
okay and class equal to number
class equal to number and here after
that the TV Tag is getting closed
okay now you have to start another TD
tag here
okay like that you keep on creating the
multiple button so let me copy
and press another table data
here
again value equal to for equal to
display
give the value equal to
and class equal to what number like that
I'll keep on creating multiple buttons
but first check how it actually looks
like it
now I can see the buttons so I can see
one two three but yes I'm going to
create few more buttons one after
another
okay so I'll go here and create few more
buttons so this is where the table data
is getting closed
okay I'll copy this
now paste it again
how to create
the button like in three four something
like that
so after this two we're giving the
vertical three
yeah
three
so value equal to 2 value equal to 3
display 3 and then afterwards
just giving the value call forward slash
and here also you're going to get the
vertical
forward slash and here class equal to
operator
after that we have to give the value
Code 4
and Then followed by six seven
so you're making four
four
five
six
after six we're giving call minus
[Music]
okay one second it will be what type of
operator
okay after this minus we'll be talking
about course seven
then we have to have a
okay nine
okay after that we're giving chord Plus
and display
plus plus equal to
operator okay so here you can see the
table data is getting closed and here
the table is also getting closed and
after this table row you can start
working with
with another table over here
and
after this table row we can start
working with again TD let me have this
again
inside this I'll be given the option
called decimal which is value equal to
Dot and here we get the vertical
decimal
okay now this will be zero
so after giving this dot it basically
take what the value 0 which we have
input now
so we're talking about value called zero
so here
the decimal value we have given it TD is
getting close let me have the another
one
zero
so like that we have to keep this now
after that maybe once again
taking this and this time rather than
giving this zero we'll be using this
call as a button and value equal to
equal to
or click equal to
solve
okay and then this song will not be
passing anything
it looks like a normal function and plus
equal to
equal
okay so table data is getting closed so
we will be using another table data now
so here it will be the button only
okay it will be using call equal to
multiplication
display
and here we'll be using operator
okay so table data is getting close
table rules getting close table is also
getting closed here
okay so your Dev tag is also getting
closed here
okay that's it
okay so that's the only thing which we
wanted to make
awesome so we have got uh all those
necessary calculator Behavior which we
wanted to
review
okay now our next statement will be once
we are giving this C then you have to
call one two three and then forward
slash followed by four five six will
come down
okay so let me check whether we view six
or not
okay so we haven't used six
so let me check here
four five six
so let me go back here
four five six let me copy this
and paste it later on
before minus
equal to
okay so we're almost set now
so we are having this
look and see in this way giving one two
three four five six and after this we
have a call minus and then plus related
Behavior so we are all set now and after
that we'll be basically applying the CSS
as well as the JavaScript look towards
my code okay thank you well everybody we
are all good to go now but I just want
to first check whether my uh this
Outlook is looking properly or not see
what my expectation is after one two
three forward slash I really want to
bring four five six to the next and then
seven eight nine end again forward slip
but I can think this is absolutely
unorganized so after this when we say
this forward slash which we have used
after hyphen okay your TD is getting
closed here
okay so here the TR I also want to close
here
okay and after this tier I also want to
start another tier here
okay so that I can put them into the
another level now so under this TR I can
use this DD now so after this minus
after four five six
minus once again I would like to start
another table row here
okay so that it lines go to the next row
so here
after TD
we're closing this Dr and starting
another tier now
okay we're starting another tier after
that we talk about seven eight nine
okay plus
see here talking about 789 plus here the
table is getting close and it is
starting right now like this
see that looks better now
okay but still few more things which I
would like to make it even more
organized but that's not a problem we
will do it later on
okay because you can see it is missing
right now so here
seven
let me copy this
equal to T8
yeah that looks better now so now they
are basically completely organized so
the moment I expect my application so we
will call Dot here then 0 then equal to
and then we will call multiplication
okay so it looks better now now I just
would like to perform the overall look
at field so I need to go ahead and use
what CSS because without CSS I really
can't utilize this in a proper way so I
have to start working with a series
first we will go back to my code and
here to my CSS we'll start working with
font family but before font family I
would like to start with the body part
now
body
background color
that looks
so
I will be using this app.css in my HTML
to see the look how it is being appeared
right now so in my index.html file
on the top under my head section
link
stylesheet
okay now see it looks better now
going forward
in my services
you want to use
some H1 color too so here
we would like to use the H1
sector
because
white merging top
margin top would like to use 50 pixels
this is for H1 let's check
perfect so it is now coming in between
next statement will be called the screen
so we say dot
screen
so in this screen we use the background
color
if I go to the gray
and after that border
border solid
black and two pixels
after that color
white font size
medium
next bit
we're using this hundred percent
then we'll talk about cursor
will be same what are the default cursor
is
then padding
you would like to say 20
.
and then margin
say Auto
then margin bottom
so the proper
ly okay
look that's how exactly we want that's
for a screen where the exact outcome
will be visible to me
and rest of the details we'll be showing
you one by one and now we'll be talking
about called input
okay
input
type
equal to button for input type equal to
button
okay into button of type mode
over the model over on my button I say
background color
to what
okay and when the button is active what
do you want let me copy
and put a little button button and here
I say
in this
like this
as you can see now how it's basically
looking like it
okay active the color will be like this
okay I'll be talking about operators
operator should behave different from
same Dot
operator
in this opportunity
I want 5 pixels
okay then I want color
that should be black
after this I'm using call border
sorry
the portal I'm using this called solid
and then black
and
after this bit
I'm using 100
then height
height is 40 pixels
then cursive
let us keep quantitative
okay that's it
perfect so they should turn back to what
to your original and you can see the
moment I take my curves on the returns
to White
perfect and now those who are type
number I also want to change them
so for number
phone number I want to say the same
option
spreading I want 5 pixels
then I need height
of time 40 pixels
then I say color
it looks I want to see called Black
that border
border I want solid
black into this for it
look
it says then with
I would say Point width I would say 100
percent
and cursor
once again
what that's for number let's check
awesome so they looks nice now we left a
few
other type of options I can Dot and
equal to
okay that is nothing but good decimal or
decimal I need to have a different
options with
Okay so
let me try to copy this
paste it and I say for
does it
so for decimal background color will be
light blue
heading 5 pixels color black or solid
okay black two pixels with 100 540
pixels fine and closer pointer perfect
okay looks nice but I have changed the
color to light blue
now
I talk about
clear
okay
now come back
and see
clear
okay in this color
background color is object
light salmon
light salmon padding 5 pixels color
black border same width hundred percent
540 pixels
fine so cursor pointer Point margin
Auto and margin bottom
margin bottom
let's check
perfect now it looks beautiful
okay
now here after giving this details we're
talking about called equal part dot
equal
so for protocol also I'm just copying
the same
so you
have a background color adding color
just change to
lightly
and
after this since it is equal so we say
padding 5 pixels is okay color black
find model find width hundred percent
High 40 pixels
color and cursor pointers just I don't
need this photo and I want
for container
container in this container with time
with 40 percent black angular White
foreign
pixels
so display block
first of all you follow it
you see
just click block
which we're taking margin
okay in March
okay now align cells
equal to send
okay border radius
border radius which is 10 pixels
okay now we're using box shadow
box Shadow 5 pixels
black
and ready
to do the retails I have it now okay
we have it background color we are
taking it now align sir display block
order radius padding and now
ready 15 pixels we've given already I
don't need to give it any merging or
fine
box here let's try
awesome so it's looking beautiful now
okay so this where exactly my
application
works like that
and table will talk about
everything width
foreign
okay
that's it
super
so it's now giving me the proper look of
how my application should be here but I
can just see about the container what we
have done
with 40 we are taking background color
let's bring it below
then align itself
display block okay margin
okay and Border radius
and uh fine I think we're all good now
so that's it so we'll try and implement
the JavaScript part well every now so
our CSS file is ready our HTML is ready
it's time to just uh
go ahead and talk about my file portion
that is called GS part where I want to
basically perform some calculators
now here I just see function
display
function display which takes that as in
parameter and Save
document dot integrated mean by ID
here I'm saying
result okay dot
value
okay
plus equal to
whatever we are adding it just it
basically try to apply calculation on
the top of that
okay here's the function
after that we have another functions
available here called function solve
here in the song
you just use the value called lit x
equal to
document dot create image by ID result
okay dot
well sorry
dot value
okay and say delete
all right
equal to
perform the calculations probably be
using one function called
either and type access and parameter
now the next statement will be again
document Dot
created by ID
Dot
value equal to y
okay now
later on
so I'll write to you another function
here
function
screen
and here we say
document
ID here we see
result
report
value equal to
like that
so clear screen
so
and
display three functions are associated
with me and these three functions are
the part of this JavaScript file which
I'll be calling it at the end before
the water tank that closed so here
's the script
equal to
I have plot yes
that's it okay let's try to execute now
here
two you can see the values
I will say plus six
equal to 8 R2 here I say C is clear the
screen
six
divided by
equal to 3. awesome so friends your
calculator application is ready
congratulations to all so it is a very
simplest form which we have developed
this is your HTML which is a template
for you this is the CSS which is your
complete
the area of like how the look and feed
will look like in of this template
beautification and here last we look at
GS which is smaller logic but really
meaningful okay
hello everyone and uh welcome to the
another very exciting project for our
development in JavaScript that is known
it's called weatherpro it is in a
continuation to the series of the
previous project what we have developed
in JavaScript and this is once again a
very competitive project I'm gonna
present to you which is called
weatherpro where I would like to offer
you the real-time weather application
into your browser taken from the
real-time weather applications okay so
let's get started with the new
development of our application which is
called a weather probe now once again
compared to the previous project what we
have seen these projects were working
more a kind of static in nature where
like you talk about snake game you talk
about Tick Tock too or other type of
games like an online quiz where the data
was very much static in nature but we
were presenting the data in the form of
more dynamic in nature this time this
project we are presenting you while
connecting with the real-time weather
application where I'll be making a one
rest API call or else you can see
asynchronous call and since JavaScript
is working as a what a pure asynchronous
nature you will be enjoying the way how
the JavaScript can communicate with your
backend load the data and represent the
records in a very very beautiful manner
so once again we would need this vs code
editor only just to develop our code and
once again
for developing a presentation part will
be using HTML for
formatting part will be using CSS and to
make some Dynamic update we'll be using
JavaScript now here I'm going to create
a new file name called index
.html
apparently I just want one more that's
not called app.css
and another file we needed and that is
called
your GS file so you're saying
up
dot GS5
so total number of three files are
available to us so I'll start working
with an HTML now and here
will start
with this
HTML templates
now here first of all I would like to
load my CSS file which I do not have
right now but certainly I can use it
okay so I can just say link
area equal to
style sheet and href
equal to
app dot CSS
well that is my CSS location
now I just want to create
some
this link area I would better use inside
my head tag that will be the more
convenient place
now in my body I want to have some of
the div tags and there I can decide
where the weather to be displayed so I
can just start with my div tag now
with my div tag I say
plus equal to I can just create a class
which later on I can offer
a different size of or different type of
styles so we can say container
so we're saying div class equal to
container now within a div tag we'll
like to use another Dev tag which is a
nested one
so this tip will have another class
called
class equal to
app hyphen
title
I have hyphen title in the same div tag
we can use
this typical paragraph tag and here we
say weather info
whether
info
now after this paragraph tag we want to
have a text box because I would expect a
client to enter the detail on which city
or for which city
he or she would like to get the details
so we can say input
some properties like ID
equal to
search
second type
equal to
text next placeholder
okay
enter
the city
next
autocomplete I'm saying autocomplete of
the reason because I do not want the
previous value user can see in this case
we can say autocomplete
off I do not want any autocomplete in
this
okay now
here it is getting close now after that
we also want the locations for that I
may use some of the PNG files and all
but right now I just want to display the
details of the user like which city he
belongs to in accordingly I can display
the records right in your application
so for that I really need some of the
dev tags once again when I get display
the details
of this particular City so I'm just
having this only text box let me go and
check go back and check
how it looks
so I have a call into the city so here
I'll be picking up the city and
somewhere down the line I have to
display
the record so
after this tip
we can also have some of the locations
to be displayed so
we can just use the notifications and
also the location where you want the
details to be displayed okay so we can
use Dev class
equal to temperature value
temperature hyphen
value
okay so div plus equal to temperature
high point value but inside this I will
be using a paragraph tag
and here is my paragraph I'll say hyphen
and this degree Centigrade or whatever
you want to display it here
and we'll use
spandex in this and show in degree
centigrade
that's it
and if you want to define the
temperature description after this Dev
tag we can use another Dev tag
and inside my Dev tag I can Define the
temperature description okay so we can
sit here
class equal to
temperature hyphen description
temperature hyphen description and
within this I'll be using what
a paragraph tag
here I'll be displaying
all the description
so right now that is the only thing
which I want let me check
okay so it's here right now so now let
me try to collect the value from the
client and perform some JavaScript tag
within this
okay now it's time for us to go back and
try to bring some of the CSS features
insert my code now now few things I
would like to say is I have basically
downloaded some fonts which I would like
to use it in my application and I also
have some of the icons which I would
like to use during my application
presentation so there are some PNG files
are there which I've downloaded from the
internet just to bring more beautiful
experience towards my application
development
well this is another background image
which is called vg.jpg which I would
like to make it as a background of my
existing application so I'll start with
my CSS and see how this CSS can really
bring some new features to my code well
first thing I need to have a called font
face so to make this font face we are
using this statement name call here at
the rate
on face and I like to use Font family
foreign family amazing
mod select
okay
it is already there with me monster it
and the URL
what is looking forward for so we are
saying SRC
URL
and I'm saying under the
font so we have a file called tdf
okay that is called
bold.df that is the file which is there
next thing
so for every
location I want to use the font family
font hyphen
family I want to use same
answer
and the next thing is like in my body
so in my body few details like
background image
I need URL and in this URL we can say
bg.jpg
in my background next thing is
background color
that I needed still blue
then I need height
I'll say 500 pixels
next your background position
all right this I needed is Center
next is your background repeat
I say no repeat
next is your background size
this I'm saying cover
this is my body part
okay let's check
okay looks awesome now you see this now
this is how my weather info is looking
like it I can see like the background
looks awesome now now next thing we
required a container
so you say dot
container container we save it
with 50 percent
next background color
which is using white
next we needed to see our align itself
that will be
Center
display
if we block
margin
so in margin you can say 100 pixels
after that border radius
border radius we are saying that pixels
and then padding bottom
this padding bottom will be 50 pixels
then box shadow
this box should be giving 5 pixels
10 pixels
20 pixels
and black
this will be with my content so
index.html file we have a call container
now
okay looks awesome now so this is where
exactly the details will be
okay now after this thesis
container we have used we can talk about
called title you can say
hyper
title
inside this we will save it
will be 100 percent
then height
will be 150
pixels
then border radius
10 pixels
then we need display
we need Flex
and then we need align items
this align items which is saying Center
next we need justify content
that will be the Justified content will
be the center
then Flex Direction
would be column
so this option we are using for our tool
name called what app iphone title
okay so here in my index.html file we
were called D plus equal to what our
python title we go to weather info let's
check
okay
so
this is the another
we have used that it's called app title
now we need to use it for paragraph
inside my app title what should be
alignment for my paragraph so here
this app title
app title space b but it should be the
class so we are saying Dot
and there also we have to use what
dot because both have to be the Class
Type
okay
so here
you can see now
there is a difference I forgot to add
Dot and now I can see it looks better
comparatively
paragraph So once again in my paragraph
I'll be having text align
Center padding
I want 15 pixels
then I need margin
margin would be zero and
Auto followed by font size font size
these are things called 1.2 here
this position then color
you're giving
hash
value call 333
okay now here
okay so some changes in a paragraph
well going forward for the search
because if you remember we have an
index.html file we have a call ID equal
to what search so here in my app Dot CSS
I have to use hash
search
okay so this search conditions I want to
use it
now inside my search I need few things
one is called display
I need block
after that I need margin left
Auto
margin right
width
I'm looking forward for five pixels
height
that I'm looking forward for 20 pixels
then border radius
foreign pixels
then outline
that's called none
let me say border
okay in this bottle what we can say
three pixels
space solid
okay and once again
that's what
let's check
foreign
block
margin
left Auto margin right Auto with 5
pixels
width
padding sorry one thing I said
hiding should be 5 pixels
width
foreign
let's check
yeah let's look better now
okay so my text box is now ready I'll be
having some of the details for the
notifications also
so what I need for the notifications
let me go back and create a class for
notification so dot
notification okay
know the notifications I would like to
give some value called background color
and in this background color we are just
giving White
and after that we are saying display
I'm using none
this is for notification and followed by
the notification
we're talking about the same
notification
okay and followed by its paragraph
we are giving the color first of all it
is in color
color is basically red
okay first if you want to give maroon
and after this
the next property we're taking is called
font size
we're taking is called 1.2
am
followed by margin
margin we are taking is zero
after that texture line
Center
adding 10 pixels
0. so this is for notification p and
then the weather container
okay in my wizard container I will save
it
100 percent
sorry here with 100 height
will be giving 260 pixels
for it to you to 50 pixels if you want
background color
this background color we are giving this
call once again White
and followed by margin top
20 pixels
20. pixels this is for weather container
now for the weather icon
weather hyphen
icon I'm saying width
is 100 percent
and height
128 pixels
just to give you a better look
now the next thing we're using Dot
weather
iPhone icon space IMG
here we're going display
none
and
sorry display not no I will say rather
block
display block and margin
giving 0 space Auto
this for Icon and location icon if I
want to give then
location hyphen
icon
this location icon I can save it same
width height
so
width I'm giving is 100 percent
then
height I'm giving 40 pixels
and then we give this option called
padding
then 10 pixels
so it's not location icon
now followed by location icon we are
also giving call location icon IMG okay
dot
location hyphen
icon space IMG
here we're giving the value called
display block
on display block with
giving is called 32 pixels
and then we're looking forward margin
margin would be 10 pixels
and
Auto
then cursor
so cursor will be pointer for sure
and then we required padding
pardon me looking forward for 5 pixels
followed by border
border we are looking forward for State
Loop
steel blue solid
and two pixels
then border radius
quarter
radius we're looking forward for 10
pixels
and followed by your color
steel blue
so these are the look and feel we have
to basically offer it for my current
application which I yet to discuss in my
next development
then I'll be having some small small
properties here
okay and those properties are nothing
but to give you the details of
like uh temperature values so we say dot
temperature hyphen value
okay this type
of value we can give it foreign
pixels
okay this is for temperature value let
me copy this again and uh
I'm giving this temperature value space
paragraph
here I'm gonna give padding
zero
margin
then color
which color you're looking forward for
we can just say dark gray
okay for any color which you're looking
forward for it's up to you now but if
you want you can change the color also
to the other one we are giving this
called hash 293
okay two five four
okay that is a more perfect color for
this development now font size
4 em
Then followed by texture line
and once again Center
so this is for temperature value p
we haven't used much
but you can see now it looks somewhere
in much more better way
okay that is called temperature value P
then you can use the temperature values
Prime
here Dot
temperature value span
space
span and here
we remove the additional Dot
now within this is spam
say color
once again save
and font size
span and in the same temperature
description paragraph you can use it
Dot
temperature iPhone description
space b
so this will be having the padding
of 8 pixels
the margin
0.
followed by color
same color the one which we have used it
earlier
foreign
Center font size
1.2 here
this is for temperature description
okay last which is available for your
location
so let me give the location now Dot
space p here we can say margin
then padding
zero
then color
same color I would like to use
after this color texture line
and font size
and copy
text align Center and here we'll be
giving some different values 0.8
okay and last which is really left with
called div in that
relative here position
I'll be using
absolute
top from Top
I'm using 600 pixels
okay and right
everything 120 pixels
okay so all set
so you can see now here we have to
basically offer the details how my
pictures will be taken it out so this is
what my CSS now we'll be applying some
of the CSS into my applying the CSS into
my HTML to see how it really looks like
it if getting your learning started it's
half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit scale up by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know more
okay so we have seen some of the CSS
classes we have introduced in my HTML we
have used this
autocomplete equal to off then we have
used strip classical root temperature
value okay if you just check carefully
we have used this temperature and if we
have used temperature hyphen value but
before that we would like to use some
other properties too
okay after this auto complete equal to
off we want to use
uh another div class okay before my
previous debt tag is closed here so here
after this people like to use another
div tag
div
here in my div
I'll say plus equal to location hyphen
icon
location hyphen
okay and here I'll be using IMG
SRC equal to what under
icons I'm using the file name called
location
dot PNG
and ALT equal to we leave it as it is a
blank
okay now here the Dev tag is getting
closed
okay now there's another Dev tag is
getting closed here
so two div tags are closed after that
we'll be using another div class for
notification here real
class equal to notification
div class equal to notification and this
step tag is getting close right here
okay now another tip for the weather
condition
another div type and here we say
class equal to weather hyphen condition
thank you
brother hyphen what a condition
or I can say whether iPhone container
whichever so I can say
weather hyphen container under this
weather container I like to use
another tip for weather icon
therefore
class equal to weather hyper icon
all right weather hyphen icon
and within this
I want to use another IMG
SRC equal to once again
icons
slash unknown
dot PNG
okay div tag is getting closed
so after this div tag is closed I'm
gonna use
temperature value
so the temperature value is anyways used
here if you see resin call temperature
value after the first step tag is closed
you see like temperature value we have
used after that the paragraph tag and
the temperature hyphen description P
after the P that the div tag is getting
close
okay and after this we are using tip
class equal to location
so we want to use
do
plus equal to
location
and within this location
we want to use one more paragraph tag
[Music]
with this hyphen
after this paragraph it's closed desktop
tag desktop tag
another type three div tags are closed
that's it and at the last
before my body tag is closed I would
like to use
SRC equal to
app
dot Js
that's it let's check
great my application looks pretty
beautiful now
so this I want to be displayed only when
I don't find the weather and the
location and also look and feel is
absolutely
good and now I'll start working on my
JavaScript
okay so let's go ahead and start writing
our JavaScript code so in this
JavaScript code first of all I need few
things
uh first thing what I need is called
individual elements or individual
properties of my application I need
const
icon element
I can remain equal to
document Dot
query selector
and I'll be using the name call
Dot
wither hyphen
icon
okay now
copy this
now we will call icon element we can say
location icon
call
here we are saying
dot location
hyphen
icon
now next I need is called temp element
we are using
the property called Dot
temperature hyphen
value space p
next we're looking forward for
desk element which is called description
here we're giving temperature hyper
description
hyphen
temperature happen description space
what
then location element
okay we need location element when we
use dot location
[Music]
next we need notification element
notification element and here we're
gonna give the call notification
notification
so four properties we have taken so we
are selecting all the elements next
statement what we're going to talk about
see this statement is all about
selecting the elements the next step we
are talking about call
get the input field so we are saying VAR
input
equal to
document Dot
get element by ID here we give the name
call
search which is the name or ID of my
text box select
City equal to blank
next we're going to cube score let
latitude
equal to 0.0 we are initializing this
value and let
longitude
let longitude equal to again 0.0 so we
are getting the coordinates right now
so this is how to get the input Fields
next we want to apply the events here we
are saying input
to variable Dot
add event listener the variable what
we're talking about which event is going
to be talking about key up
okay
up and what even do you want to apply so
we are saying
function with a parameter name called
what
event and now we would like to attach
the logic now we're saying if
what are the condition
event Dot
key code
equal to
30.
okay
then
that means number 13 is basically the
inter
see the key code means what 13 13
represent the enter keyword so event.key
code equal to what 13 so we are saying
event
dot prevent default why we're using this
because I do not want my page to be get
refreshed just to avoid this we are
using this and after that we are saying
City
equal to
input Dot
value
now you'll be using this or other
function because I do not have function
created otherwise I have to call the
function name called get search whether
I'll be passing this as in parameter so
we will get
searched
whether I do not have this function I
yet to create this and pass it here as a
what
City and you say console DOT log
City whatever we are basically printing
it
okay
so that is the first thing later on we
need to get the data so to get the data
we are just using this variable name
called const
whether
equal to const whether equal to
curly places
after that we are saying
whether Dot
temperature
equal to this
and which temperature conditions you
want on the same unit
of type what Celsius
I wanted a Celsius
okay
so next statement will be
getting the details in kelvin I'm saying
const Kelvin
equal to value of the Kelvin is what 273
and after that
go on C ultimately what we need is we
need to interact with our backend API
from where I will get or receive the
updated weather applications
okay now
to get this I'll be using one very
popular API here that is known as call
open weather map.org
this is all very very popular app which
people use it and it's used and trusted
by many companies
clear so here
what you can do this open with a map.org
so you need to basically first of all
get yourself registered because if any
third party application is interacting
it requires that particular unique API
key
since as a visitor you really can't get
it unless you register yourself so I
have
my APK with me so I'll go here
It'll ask me for the registration
so I already signed up so if you're not
easy to sign it there's an API key for
me which I need to copy and this API key
I'll be using it in my project
so I just use this property called const
k equal to
paste my key here
okay after this pasting the key but make
sure that you rather using my key you
use your key otherwise this application
sometimes won't work
so I'm basically trying to use this tool
name for jio location
I'm saying if
geo location
okay and Navigator
Navigator is unit is a browser object
model element
so here we are using
Navigator
okay Navigator Dot
jio location
Dot
get current position in which I'll be
passing the first parameter new convert
set position
and second parameter will be show error
in case if any error is received
okay
else
in the sales condition what would happen
I'm using this statement in call
notification
element
if it is notification element Dot
style Dot
notification remain Dot
get Elements by class name
but I don't need this rather I will use
what the style
dot display equal to
block
then I'll be using the same
notification element Dot
inner HTML equal to You're Gonna use a
paragraph
saying what browser
doesn't
support
so you have to enable the current
location of use
okay that's where exactly so after that
we have to basically set what the user
position
okay if the user is having that support
available
so after this
location we'll be just using another
function here
function
set
foreign
it will I'll be taking
position as a parameter
and take latitude
latitude equal to
position Dot
Chords chords for coordinates Dot
latitude
okay like that
longitude
equal to
what position Dot
chords
Dot
longitude
after this we'll be using this function
called what
get
weather so this get weather will be the
function in which you will be passing it
so this function will be soon see I'll
be having it defined below but as of now
we are just saying
get feather and in which this we are
passing
latitude and
longitude
that's it
so we have this functioning called what
set
position in which we'll be passing all
the values
okay at the same time
I'll be using one more function here
that is called function
not function in fact
I would like to use location
icon the one which you defined on the
top part
add event listener which even listener
I'm saying
one click
second
function which take
event is in parameter
and inside this I'm saying console just
to confirm whether the records have been
taken console.log
hey just and
we say get with it
okay one second we'll be passing what
latitude and longitude same I just copy
this
and paste it here
okay everyone so we have written till
here when I try to run my browser so I
should see there is a message name
called show error is not defined but
obvious because this message what we're
writing it here called show error okay
this as a function as a parameter it is
not defined let me Define this function
called show error so we are saying
function
show error which take
errorism sorry just take
errorism parameter
in this we are using
notification
Dot
Style
dot display equal to what
block
after that once again
notification element Dot
inner HTML
equal to what
we're just using this as a paragraph
and here
Dot
message
okay and after that
paragraph
so this is how we are basically writing
it down
and now
see it is immediately asking you
to know your location okay if I say
allow
that's okay
okay so nothing
you can see now it is saying get weather
is not defined because right now the
moment I click on this
so it is saying like get weather is not
defined but obvious because I told you
this great weather function I need to
develop so I get to develop this
function called get weather but before
that I'm using another function called
function
get search weather
okay
search whether in which I'll be passing
what
city name now what exactly my API will
be in case if I want to make a call I
will be using let
API equal to now the URL will be what
HTTP colon double forward slash API Dot
open
weather map Dot org now open weather
map.org
slush
data slash two point
sorry 2.5 that is a version slash
weather okay question mark
I have to take the city dynamically so
I'm saying whether
question mark Cube
equal to
here
we're using what city
and where is the amp percent
app ID equal to double app ID we have
used it already
okay what is that key
so that is a key which you've already
written that app ideally we are passing
it right over here
okay Q equal to city and have I equal to
this
now after that to make the restful API
call I'll be using one independent or
by default API which is available to us
that is one is called what fetch
okay so if you just check this fetch it
is basically a take request info and
give you the word a promise response so
return type will be the promise type in
this fetch I will be passing what
the API
and we'll be using dot then that means
if the request
is successful using function
function
response
then function is a parameter response we
are saying let
data equal to
response dot I'm expecting the responses
type of what Json is in Json now and
return what
data
so it will be returning data back to me
now if it is successful then what then
say dot then once again it is chaining
okay function again
parameters now in this case we'll be
getting lot of things I am saying
whether
okay dot
temperature it's a predefined DOT
value equal to I'm using what
math Dot
flow inside this we are crossing code
data Dot main dot temp it is a
predefined property we are receiving it
now hyphen
Kelvin what are the Kelvin values
basically we're taking score 273 on the
top
minus Kelvin
followed by
another property what
weather Dot
description
whether dot description
equal to we're using data Dot
whether
zeroth position because it contains a
lot of data but I will be taking what
description out of that then
weather Dot
icon ID
whether or not I can ID equal to
data
Dot
weather
icon then
dot icon then once again
weather Dot
City
okay equal to
data Dot
name
after this
weather.country
Dot
equal to
data Dot sys Dot
so these are the properties I have it
right now with me
okay and once I received all the
property I'll be using Dot
then
I'll be using one function
and I will say what
display there is no function written
called display weather but I'm gonna say
there's a one function name called
display together
this function I have to write
but this function just putting it here
okay now this is closed after that
since I need to get a weather from the
API provider so I have to also pass what
the latitude and longitude which I am
receiving it from the client because
here I just want to have two things the
properties as well as whether both and
both I'll be using it one by one okay so
here we have kept this get search
weather and now I'll be calling one more
function after this logic and I'm giving
the name call function
get weather
okay it takes two parameter one is
called what latitude and second is
called
longitude so we have two things called
attitude and longitude and here I'm
using this property called what lit
API equal to once again if you remember
uh I have used this statement I'll just
copy the same
and password it here
but challenge would be this time
I will not be passing city name because
the two options are available either you
type the city name or else you click on
the icon and let your application
identify the location which you belong
to
so after this weather question mark
here I will not be using Q I'm using
what led
equal to
latitude
okay
and we're using and
Halloween
equal to
we're using longitude
okay and applied equal to what key so
this is the variable which we have it
now
okay now similar thing which we have
used it on the top
okay called Fetch API so I just copy
this same fetch API again
because I really don't want to waste
time on keep on typing the code when we
know it very well it can be similarly
done I just copy and
paste it here so the same fetch API dot
then response data equal to
response.json return data then
display weather so we have used the same
thing here and after that we have to use
the last function here that is called
display weather
display weather and here in my display
weather I can use
what icon element Dot
inner HTML equal to
I'll be using
IMG
SRC
equal to
icons
slash dollar
and we'll be passing what weather
okay dot
icon ID
PNG
Okay so
that we are basically putting it here
dot PNG and after that
we're just closing that
okay and this icon we also need to close
here
rather than closing this I'll be closing
that and
this I'll be closing it here
now
we'll be using top element
sorry temp element
Dot
inner HTML equal to what
we'll be using this dollar
weather Dot
temperature Dot
value okay and after this value we can
just use
this asterisk sign
the one which I told you
okay and use
expire
okay next we are using called Talk
element
so we have okay sorry DAC limit
we have for DEC element Dot
inner HTML equal to
weather Dot
description
and last but not least location
element Dot
inner HTML equal to
what
I'll be using one second this
and here
weather Dot
City
comma
dollar
weather Dot
that's it these two properties we have
to use it
and we are all done let's check with my
code
if I get any error
now
allow
so
awesome you can see now
27 broken clouds Globe undefined that's
perfectly fine Intercity
awesome beautiful it is showing you the
conditions it's like smoke 28 degree
centigrade in and on let me put another
city here I'm gonna say called Pune
awesome your application is working
perfectly fine
and uh
let's see one more
I would say
awesome if getting your learning started
is half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit scale up by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know more
and now we are planning to develop our
very special game for you
in JavaScript in now it's time to talk
about another very interesting game that
is known for Tic Tac
tic-tac-toe is world's favorite game we
have already played a lot in our
Childhood Days and still my favorite
game so I have decided to basically
offer you this tic-tac-toe game
developed in JavaScript HTML CSS which
can create something really really great
effects for the end users so let's go
and start developing our next game
that's called tic-tac-toe so in this
tic-tac-toe I will start working with
creating a folder called Tic Tac and
inside this I'm going to create a new
file name called index
dot HTML
now here onwards the same thing
I'll be creating this HTML tags
and now here onwards
we want our some classes for headers and
footer but so we're going to create some
Dev diagram
so in this div tag
I'll be creating some of the tags
in which the CSS class will be applied
so we just gonna create a classes
for languages use those classes but
we'll create it later on so just go
ahead and create those so using div
okay
so now this point onwards is my first
step tag inside this I'll keep
my H1 tag
and under this H1 I will be offering
some of the headings which will be
useful
to contain some necessary information
with regards to this game so tip here we
say H1
and inside this H1 we give the message
called class
equal to header
and here I'll give the name call
is a Tic Tac token
after this div class
here we will start working with our form
tag
within my form tag I will start my div
after div tag I will use label
so label for player one
or else I can say player one and inside
this let's give the name call
ER
labor is closed and after this label
will start working with our input tag
input
now in this input what are the details I
need first I need to call type equal to
number one second
placeholder equal to enter name
next name
equal to layer 1
next we want ID equal to
layer 1 and then
any class if I want to play
anyways we're going to close this this
is my first text box and same thing I
would like to create for my another one
so the first dip tag we have used let me
go and create another tip tag
in this div tag I'll use the same label
copy the same
paste it here and this is for play 2.
so we have this two players with me and
after this div tag and offer the submit
button now
input typically subnet
start game
now the form tag is closed here
Dev tag is also closed
so you want a div tag to be closer
before that it's up to you now so here
we have a card dim class
whichever we have taken so if you want
you can basically put it later or before
whatever
so we have a basically form that with us
so form tag is there later on you can
just show some containers where the
details will be visible to me so here
after the form tag
let me try to offer but first check
whether it's really working fine
so here
yeah we have this option called enter
name internet so
[Music]
yeah so here the details we have taken
input available text and then put up a
little text
okay so two values we are taking now and
accordingly we go ahead now finally
after the form tag
we would like to start with working with
the Dev tag again
div and inside this div
I since I haven't created any CSS
classes so those we can use it little
later on but let's have this tip
and insert this tip I would like to use
remote depth type
okay and here we want to use one more
div tag
so inside this tip we will be using one
more div tag
so in this div we can just give the
value called Data ID equal to zero
are equal to
zero it's just a value we are passing it
div data is equal to zero the div tag is
getting closed
fine so that's how we want it now so
here the first step tag is closed like
that we can create another data ID so 0
1 2 total number of three we want to
create it so I want to create 0 1 2 3 4
5 like this so the way we have created
here
for this div let's go and create one
more div tag
ID equal to
2.
three options we have it now
okay like that I can keep on creating
the others also
true
three
four
five so zero one two three four five
total number of five we operated
one more I would like to create it now
here for six
there'll be no difference because we
haven't changed anything here
okay so the div tag is getting closed
here
okay and uh
that's it
and if you want to create some clear
border button that you can basically
offer it a little later on but here
we can use one more dim
and here we say Dev
class equal to relating
and within this type I can use any image
tag if I want
so I just leave it as it is
and after this I can create one more tip
type
and inside is another tip
okay and under this I'm going to create
a button
okay and in this button
will be having some value okay we can
secure the value name called replay
this button is created and now we can
create a clear board
span
and here is a clear board
that's it
okay so here
is just
a small game I want to develop it
better now there's no user interface has
been used so this user interface will be
using it later on by offering them a
pure look at field so that you know it
gives me more better look when your
application will start
but most importantly I need to start
working with a JavaScript part where the
logic will get calculated here
Okay so
we want to start with the JavaScript so
let's get included a JavaScript with my
code
so here
I can see here script tag
script
equal to
now the file I haven't created so let it
be as it is
that's it so this is my script tag and
let me try to include my style sheet
also so I just say
link are you equal start sheet
thank you the name called app Dot
see says go I haven't created but I'm
giving it
okay
that's it
so we have taken this HTML into over
consideration now we'll be creating this
CSS as well as the JavaScript to make
this example complete
well we are ready with our HTML but it's
time to basically go back and spend time
on our JavaScript we're going to create
a new file now with the name called
app.js and inside this we will start
writing the logic with our main
application okay now the first thing is
how we gonna start now yeah so first
thing what we need to do is we need to
attach window
Dot
add event listener and when the window
will load some logic should happen so
I'm saying load
second is the name of the function
so the name of the function perhaps does
not exist but I can give the name call
app which I'm going to create it shortly
now here first of all let me try to
create a game mode I'm saying lit
game board
equal to now let me have some of the
values because it is
eight digit
so we just make it
like that
and one more
for making it right
okay so that's how we're going to create
it now
okay now this is all empty right now
of that we're going to create lit
turn
this new variable equal to zero what
this is it keep tracking if x or zero
player it's done
like which player turns it will be
suggest it is trying to measure it so
I'm saying let
ters equal to
pause
okay now let's go and create the player
so
create
okay how are you going to create a
playlist const
player equal to what you're gonna pass
name
okay equal to
now inside this we can say name equal to
name
next we say return
that's it
okay after that I'm defining lit
here
x equal to
clear
with the empty value
and again
player y
equal to layer is an empty value now
let's try to initialize the app
okay
initialize
inside this initialized app we're going
to create a new function
function out
and inside this we're going to create a
variable likewise saying let
input feed
equal to first of all
document dot get element by ID here
we're gonna take
the class name of this particular text
field so we are saying input
iPhone
field
okay dot
Focus
okay now after this we have to say const
add players
equal to once again
document Dot
get element by ID we'll just give the
new code player form
okay next we are saying add
hello
okay dot
add event listener we want to attach the
event on which event
submit event and what logic
add players
okay after that once the plates are
added we are saying let replay
button equal to once again
document sorry yeah
dot get element by ID or rather I will
say document.query selector
document dot query selector
replay type
BTN
okay it will adjust the name we are
basically taking that and here we say
sorry
replay button Dot add event listener
which even I want to say
click
okay that is the first event second
reset code
reset mode
that we are basically passing out
okay now
this is the initial case which we have
it now beyond that I will add this is
the place what we have added right not
slides to add the players so this is how
we've initialized after that let's
third
Place how to basically add the players
here we have to just Define the function
that
plays
okay so take
event as a parameter
and say event
Dot
prevent
default this prevent default will try to
prevent the default
uh you know Behavior which is submitting
to be get avoided and now here we say if
this Dot
player one so we just Define the
property called player one
if this dot layer 1 dot what
value
okay
is blank
okay or
foreign
now I just want to find it out its value
also
value
black
then what I should do in this case I am
saying alert
you
almost
enter name
for
each
the user has to add the values and after
that
editor
okay now the next thing is like we would
like to select the plates in this inside
is by saying calls
player
form
container
okay const play from controller
container equal to document Dot
query selector
query selector here we will just pass
the value column
enter icon
okay place
okay now we say const
ant
equal to
foreign
dot once again
query selector
code underscore I mean
okay after that
player form container
Dot
class list
dot class list Dot and here we've given
the name for our height container
all right
and after that you just say board mail
board main dot class list
Dot
remove
hide hyphen container
okay so we are basically taken that and
after this what I will do I'll just say
player
x dot name equal to this Dot
player one
Dot
value
okay this is for player x copy this
player y
2 and after that
that's it so we have done it now
so
will be calling other functions one by
one but that is the first thing which we
have implemented
well so add player function is added
right now and after this add player we
have to basically call one more that is
called which Returns the current player
so I'm saying returns
current player
and here what I will do is we'll just
write function
and here we say
current
player and in this current player what
we will do is
we will say return
just variable
okay percentile
we're just adding it with this
zero
okay if it is
then X turn I'm telling you
okay or else
so we are in like the current player who
says the current player right now
well after this adding the return
current player we're gonna add another
function that is known is called return
the current flavor written current
player is having this value and after
that we need to say resize the square in
event browser is resized once again if
the browser is getting resized
automatically the square size of your
Tic Tac Toe should also get increased so
we just say
precise
of course
and here we're gonna say this option
equal window
Dot
add
event listener
now we have a call option called resize
here and the second parameter what
you're passing is called
resize
okay on resize
foreign
after this we are writing this function
called
function
resize that is the functioning for me
the one which you are passing into the
second parameter
we are saying let all cells
equal to
document
Dot
query selector all
in this we are passing
board
underscore
okay and then we're using another option
called what lit
cell height
equal to
all cells
with the position
okay dot of set width
of
set width
after that we are saying all cells
Dot
for each here we are passing cell
and after that we are using cell
Dot
style Dot
height
equal to now you'll be using this
backtick and the uses
dollar side and say
height
and that way in a pixel
so this will be taking the dynamic
values
okay that's it that's it over now we
have to just launch our build board
now
billboard
build
so how are we gonna build our board now
for this we are saying function
all right
billboard
and inside this billboard we will see
this option called let
reset
container equal to
document Dot
once again query selected and pass the
value called dot reset
okay and after that we are saying reset
container Dot
class list
dot remove
and we are passing the value call
reset hyphen
hidden this value and after that
we may call some other type of functions
also okay so for those functions I can
say first will be called on
resize
okay
after that we are calling add some click
listener
but I do not have that function with me
these functions we need to create it by
our own
okay so we will just link those for a
time being let's go back and create
another functions now so we just want to
write another event with cell click
event for play to attempt to make move
so here we are trying to say foreign
click
event
for
player 2.
attempt
to make
now this function we need to create it
so we just say function now
we just say function and give the name
of the function to make move Now
function make
move it takes
if it doesn't parameter
and here we are saying console.log
and sector
now let's go back and try to check the
another condition that is called let
current cell
equal to
percent because you have to read the
value from there and here we are saying
what event Dot
current Target
sorry
even Dot current Target Dot
first element child
okay dot
data set
Dot ID
so we're reading these values after that
we use another variable called it
cell two
add
token now here we are typing document
dot query selected
and here
you know using backtick I'm using this
vertical
data hyphen ID
okay equal to
here we are using once again in a single
quotes
dollar
current cell
okay so this value we are taking it like
that
after that we are using this situation
called if
cell to add token Dot
inner HTML
extra material mark
black
once again if Cell to add
token dot inert HTML equal to blank then
what next
so sell to add token dot inner HTML
equal to blank then what you should do
I'm saying console
DOT log
and give the value the one which you
want
okay so in this console.log what value
we can give it
sell to a token
we have it it is taking this value to
the current cell dot inner HTML
console.log and inside my console.log we
can set this
cell is
already
take care
so values are already taken for this and
now we will be returning those values
after that we will be using else
condition
and here we use once again if
foreign
then we'll be using this option called
cell
see we have this property option
available called send to add tokens so
we're using cell to add token okay dot
text content
equal to
current player
foreign
this value called
current cell and in this correct cell
value will be equal to
okay else
we can say
to add token Dot
text content equal to
current player
okay and say
game board
current cell
equal to
like this
okay so here we are adding the values
like that
so it is closed after that we can just
use the function name code is winner to
check whether the user is winner or not
so we are saying is
winner
okay and after that we are saying
done
plus plus
after that we are saying
change
we do not have the function name called
change board header names
okay so it's just like that we're giving
it so as usual we can leave this
function for a time being and we'll call
this little later on so
and if it is a full time being
okay so your function is now ready
so the next thing what we need to check
whether
it is tie or not okay so we are saying
function
check
if
I
was just taking the function
whether it is game is tie or not so here
we say if the condition is turned
greater than 7
alert
okay we can say give over as we can see
our time
okay well after that we are saying
winner
function
is winner
now what it will check is you will check
const
winning sequences
winning sequences and here
sorry here we are having this array and
having the different conditions
Associated we say zero
one two probability we are checking it
and then I just copy it
well we are saying 0 1 2 and here we say
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
and zero three six again
zero
three
six
and once again one four seven
four
seven
and next we have a call 258
eight
then we are checking the vertical zero
for it
and one more last option we will put is
equal to four six
so these conditions we are adding
after this array we can say
winning sequence is stored
for each
and give an equal winning compost
ready
combos
and inside this winning compost we are
giving lit
cell 1 equal to
winning combos position 0
then
copy
and paste three times
cell two
cell three
and here we get the radical what one
two three words are giving it and after
that we are checking the condition let's
say
if
any other conditions you're checking
what exactly that will be for the game
board we are saying
game board
seven
one
foreign
player
sorry
current player
Ampersand time percent
come down
game board
I just want to copy this the same line
and paste it multiple times
now here
we are checking the condition for cell 2
and cell 3
and
cell three and after that
we're starting the position
so after that
we're starting the position call
[Music]
recording this condition call
cells caused
cells and then equal to
document Dot
get element by or sorry document.query
selector
query selector all right here let's
select the position Dot
board
underscore
okay then after that we will be using
cells
Dot
for each
cell
and inside is what you're passing we are
saying let
cell ID equal to
cell Dot
first
element child
okay dot
data set
dot ID so this is the value which you
are basically adding it now and we're
using one more different condition
pressing if
cell ID
now we're talking about wholesale ID
triple equal to
cell one
or
salary
cell ID equal to
cell 3 okay and in that case we can use
cell Dot
class list
plot add
get the name for board
just give the class name
so here we'll be giving the winner and a
part of that we can use the other
conditions today
okay so here it is adding the value and
now let's say
let
current player equal to
document Dot
get element by ID
so you can basically Define it so
current player you want so we can use
the current player or whichever
conditions you want so here we use what
the cell winner now Small Change rather
than using curve clear we can use
the current
player text
a new variable we are creating it
current create text document dot rather
than same get element by ID
you can see query selector
and in this query selector you'll be
giving the value by saying dot board
player
hyphen turn
the value which you are given it here
and that query selector
value whichever you've given this let me
try to put it here parenthesis
like this
okay now here we just checked
if current player
X
then what
then in this case we can say
current player whatever the value we are
using current text plot
inner HTML
equal to now we can Define the value
whichever you want to offer it
we just use a condition called div
class equal to
okay so we are saying congratulations
and here we say
congratulations along with
this dollar sign
and here we pass
player try Dot
name
and here the tip tag is getting closed
like this
okay so that's the message we are
basically printing it and after that we
give this value
and say this message call
winner equal to
true
and after that
if you want to apply
remove
that function we haven't written we'll
be talking about a little later on and
just say return purely
so your function is ready now
and later on we can just check the
condition if winner
if
winner
all right
we can say
check if I
am
written Force
that's it
now in a continuation to this example we
are going to develop another function
which
the name is called change board header
names so let's continue by defining the
new function called function change
all right
board header names
so this change Port header names will be
the new function for us and here we
would like to check whether the user is
winner or not so here we say if
not
winner
then what
then in that case we have to select
current player text equal to
document Dot
query selector in this we'll be getting
the details like Dot
code
and here we're gonna give the name
called player
and hyphen turn
player hyphen term
now later on after this particular
variable we have to just check the
condition by saying if
current player
equal to X if the position is X sorry
let me try to put it in capital letter
here
X
then we have to say
current player Dot
inner HTML equal to now here we have to
just use the same option called back
text because I want to go multi lines
that's the benefit of this Factory and
here we say in our inner HTML span
foreign
hyphen
Style
close this and here we want to use
the statement now this
value we want to write it with name
attribute so it is getting close and
here we are saying dollar
with this player
x dot
name
and then
closer span tag and we say
you are
like this and after that
we say div
class equal to which is going to create
a class which later on we can apply the
CSS Style on the top of that U hyphen R
hyphen
winner
and here we say closing the diff type
so the div tag is closed that's it and
now after this line
for next we have this called else
condition
else
what else here we say
current layer
text
dot inner HTML
energy table equal to
after this
we're gonna write the spam
class equal to here we say email
same option we're gonna use it so in
this condition so winner conditions so
let me try to copy this C rather than
copying it again and again
I'll just copy the whole text
span class equal to name hyphen hyphen
style player rather than saying X we
have to use y you are up you are
Fitness
okay so here it's getting closed
well after this what we have to do
create another function called reset
code
function
reset board
now in this function reset board we just
say console.log
a small message
resetting
resetting is added now afterwards we
will be using the game board now the
same game board what we have used it
earlier
I'll be using the same conditions
on the top
if you remember that was the game code
for me so I'll be using the same game
board
the copy this
yeah
with the same condition
okay gameplay could do this after that
line we will say that
sell to add token
sell to add token equal to
document dot query selector all
here
in this I'll be using another class call
later
now
sell to add token
whichever we've used Dot
for each
Square
and within this Square we would like to
use Square
Dot
text content equal to Black
after that
Square
Dot
parent element Dot
class list Dot
remove
and here you would like to say both
okay underscore underscore
sell
ER so these classes we have to create
because these CSS classes we are just
using this but we haven't created we'll
be using it little later on
so that was the point
now after that we are defining the turn
value
turn
equal to zero because we are resetting
it and
winner equal to
false
after that win is equal to false we just
Define another variable called Define
let current player text
current layer text equal to
document
Dot
query selector all
so here we're gonna use the name call
board
Define player hyphen hyphen turn
after that current player
current player
text
currently text Dot
inner HTML equal to once again we have
to use the condition for up
and winner point so let me try to copy
this
inner HTML equal to
okay and in this we have to say
playerx.net
okay just everything is same
no change at all
okay now
here after that we're gonna write one
more function called function
foreign
listener that means when I will be
adding or clicking something to myself
what kind of event I would like to
listen here
we are saying const
cells equal to
document
Dot
query selected all
let's check
the condition board
[Music]
cell and here once again we say sell
stock for each
Dot
for each
and here this is cell Dot
add event listener
which event I want to listen
click and the second parameter will be
Handler
on score
might move
okay and this function which we have
created called add self clicks listener
okay this I'll be calling it here
perfect
later on once it is done let's try to
add one more function called function
remove
foreign
click
listen
remove cell click listener
now here we say let
all
cells equal to
document Dot
query selector all
let's pass
board
cell and now we say
all cells Dot
for each
cell
and here we say send Dot
remove
event listener
which event
click
and second parameter will be
make
that's it so friends now here most of
our JavaScript code is written now so
going forward we would like to use CSS
and finally we'll be applying everything
into our HTML file
well after the Javascript file is ready
towards my application now it's time to
go and create our HTML file now sorry
the CSS so inside my Tic Tac I have got
app.js and index.html ready now here I'm
going to create another file here called
app.css see you can basically put this
app dot CSS in either folder like in
static folder but I have just kept it
outside
now from this point onwards I would like
to start with my basic functionalities
okay what those are let's start with the
first feature called morning
with my body
some basic settings I would like to do
like in background image background
color so I just start with
background color
background color I can just use it as a
white
okay but I don't think it's really
needed it so if you want you can have it
otherwise leave this background color
because it's by default gonna be white
only
and now next would be called height
height will be 800 pixels
next background position
background position I just say like
Center
next background repeat in case if you do
not want to repeat the image
background repeat
and here I say no repeat
next background size
here using cover
so it resize the background image to
cover the entire container
okay so that's what the body part now
the next thing is we have to select the
rest of the CSS classes first select div
dot relative
inside is date dot relative is for
Circle position
position we are saying absolute
next is stop
from the top I'm just making 760 pixels
next right
right here's the same 120 pixels
next
after this we are saying height
container
height Dot container or sorry height
hyphen container
here in hide hyphen container we will
display
colon
well after that we have to use the
header point
header
inside the seller we will say color will
be by default white but still we just
say color
and
White
next text line
we just say Center
next margin
margin will be 50 pixels
next font family
font family I'm selecting call permanent
Michael
permanent
okay
permanent marker
okay next class we are talking about
call interplayer let's call Dot
enter
hyphen
players
I need to hyphen players with the same
color
will once again
we can use another layer but we can just
use white or any color you want or you
can just use
there's
okay
margin
margin we're giving it is called zero
Auto width
we're looking forward for 80 percent
next text align
Center
position
now next we're going forward for input
field
in this input field we just say border
border 2 pixels
solid
and black
next outline
outline none I do not want any outline
to be there
next padding
I can take 4 pixels
8 pixels
4 pixels 8 pixels now margin
we're saying zero
zero 10 pixels
okay and finally four pixels
after switching we say font size
18 pixels
okay so that is your input field next we
are talking about something called input
field Focus
input
hyphen field
okay colon
Focus
now here
border
2 pixel
solid
or any other color which you want to use
it
next
how you want to submit button to be so
I'm saying Dot
submit hyphen bdn
border
two pixels
solid
and black
adding
8 pixels
and again eight pixels
font size
80 x
now with
250 pixels
followed by border radius
5 mixes
next your margin from Top
let's take 10 pixels
after that background color
let's take y20
okay
so this is the property
now going forward you can associate with
your submit button active and submit
button Focus so we are saying Dot
submit hyphen vtn
cooler
active
and
two options we are taking
followed by condition outline now
outline
next border
we're talking about equal to pixels
solid
and the color
right
okay
so that's the one
and after that we'd like to use hover
Dot
submit hyphen button colon
over
what you want
change the background color to what
white
you can use white smoke
well
here we'd like to use a
Dot
board
here we'd like to use player
hyphen
these are the classes we were using in
our JavaScript we remember
and here we say color
we're using once again
white or you can use this white smoke
whichever you want
so
well later on text align
okay
set to margin
10 pixels
and 10 pixels
height
54 pixels
okay
so these are the properties initially we
have taken
okay so after this
so let's go and start another classes
here I'm saying Dot name hyphen hyphen
style and here we are seeing color
red
and then font size
22 pixels
well
now coming back to the another
properties now we're talking about a
next report called border container
called board container plot
about container here we Define width
which is 40 pixels we are taking
or sorry 40 we can really take
after that background colors
that we can say coded blue
okay next margin
we're taking is a zero
and
Auto
after that font size
font size we are taking zero
next border
border we are taking two pixels
then solid
and then black
followed by
box shadow
if you remember this worksheet is one of
the very very season
three popular property here we are
defining three pixels
3 pixels
zero pixels
and RGB we can talk about called Black
okay so my border color will be shading
color will be black
after that we're offering this board
cell
Dot
now in this board cell we are defining
width
now in this width we are using
calculation
CA LC and in this calculation we are
defining hundred percent
okay divided by tree
this calculation after this the next
property will be displayed
display will be inline block
next font size
we're taking 40 pixels
well texture line
Center border
we are taking two pixels
solid
and
black
adding 20 pixels
vertical align
top
next for family
this formula can use permanent
permanent markers
okay now
next option a part of this we have a
call your board civil
board
cell hyphen
winner
I would say rather type
no it's going wrong this is 3D here Port
circular let's make background color
okay and
[Music]
later on just use
letter
now in this letter we just give the
color combination so color will be
White
next position
relative top
50 percent
next transform
translate by
2 minus 50 percent
after that font family
we are making it once again permanent
marker
foreign
copy
okay now here next option will be called
winner container here we're giving
winner
with DOT
Dot winner hyphen
container
okay so for this winner container what
are the values we want to use it that's
you want to basically do it so if all
this winner container what I would
rather suggest is you can use Dot
reset
text line
Center
margin
20 pixels
that is for reset and now reset hidden
inside this reset here we will set
display now
display
num
okay after this the replay button
it's yeah I'm going to talk about replay
button Dot
replay hyphen
video and here width
we make it through
25 percent
okay and followed by padding
10 pixels we take it from here and 20
pixels
border
this bottle we are taking is called two
pixels
followed by solid
okay and black color
now later on Border radius
border radius we're taking 5 pixels
later on outline
and signal
after this outline we say later spacing
now this little spacing would be again
zero
after that
text transform
this text wrong form where we are
talking about call
uppercase next font size
font size we're taking 16 pixels
then margin top
margin top would be 12 pixels
then word spacing
that you're taking 3 pixels
followed by background color
so this is for your replay button
okay now in a similar line we can also
have
call Dot
replay hyphen BTN
colon over
followed by Dot
replay hyphen
active
now apply the common style outline
we are making it null
that color
we are making it is called White
then background color
will be black
okay and when it comes to the
congratulations
so we'll be using this Dot
thank you
okay so this congratulations class will
be using font size
to what 24 pixels
and after this we are using this call
winner dot U
hyphen r dot winner
in this winner we'll be taking
font size
okay that's 18 pixels
after that height
we are taking 18 pixels again
then line height
line height we are taking 18 pixels
and then
margin two pixels
and then zero
okay that's it so
last but not least we would like to use
this Dot
replay
hyphen BTN
this I'm saying with 50 percent
50 percent
so this is what my C6 file is all set
I know it was pretty lengthy but it is
required for this particular application
okay everyone so we are all ready with
our CSS also now it's time to go back to
our index.html file and take care about
the final finishing touch so we have
this index.html file with us and now the
CSS class which we were using it in our
application that is known as call this
uh
permanent marker this class is not by
default available so we have to include
this using this external API so here
where we have a call CSS with us before
that
we want
link
So within this link we want our variable
name called href
equal to now we have to give the proper
location by saying https
colon double forward slash fonts
dot Google apis
okay.com
slash CSS
question mark
family equal to
permanent
Plus
marker
okay so if you just copy this
into your browser you will get to know
where exactly it is using okay if I just
copy and paste it
so I just need to say https before
yeah https
fonts Dot
Google apis
.com slash or spelling ground
CSS family equal to permanent marker
that is the main URL from where I can
take this kind of font so here
CSS so that's what I was cross verifying
it well it's there we have included our
CSS also but in which class we need to
use that is an important now
JS I also want to include it
so here in my head tag only I would like
to include
script
SRC code tool
app.js
so here my script is actually loaded now
after that
if I just go back and check
the final outcome of my code
which is index.html file
well it pretty much look like in basic
nothing else has started when we talk
about called start game
okay so it needs to start because there
is no CSS class are attached so I need
to attach those classes within my code
so here onwards we have to start with
offering those CSS classes so that at
least I can apply those common behaviors
to my application
okay like here we have a call
div we haven't attached any class to
this after this body we have a div H1
class equal to header tic-tac-toe then
we have a called div we have a call
body
uh under this we have a call another Dev
tag so just imagine how many type of
classes are available one we have a call
to class equal to header
div class is closed again we have a call
one more div tag so like that multiple
CSS files are there where we have to
apply the new CSS class to make it
happen so now we have to just go back
and change our HTML and to apply our
main class
so this is what my final HTML which
looks like the same you can see we have
added all those type of csys classes
which we had that is called interplayer
player form player container level
placeholder and player container and if
you see all different type of classes we
have attached this to
okay because
here only my CSS class will get applied
and the JavaScript will apply those kind
of dynamic CSS based on certain
conditions so these CSS classes are
already there added inside your HTML
page our app CSS is ready
app.js is also ready let's go back and
try to reveal how it looks like it
awesome so it looks like pretty nice
tic-tac-toe is again it is expecting
when it says start game it says You must
enter a name for each field validation
is working let me try to add
two names and say start key awesome so
now you can see it is saying hey you are
up now let me try to give the values
awesome now you can see it's saying like
hey you are a winner great so guys
congratulations on this is the first
example of how the tic tac toe game is
used so it is a classical example of CSS
JavaScript and HTML together so this
time we're gonna talk about our next
very interesting feature that is
launched called dealing with another
example that is called snake game so
snake is one of the very very powerful
example which I'm gonna share with you
which will help you to understand like
how we offer a very simplest way of
developing a mini project okay that is
something which is a snake game let's
see how the snake game is important and
how we're gonna deal with this these are
our previous examples which we have seen
which I will call a project which we
have created that is called quiz
application and now we're going to start
working with our new project now here
first of all I'm going to create a new
folder that is called snake
again
and inside this is a snake game we need
some new folders uh first folder I'm
going to create it inside this that is
called images
and within this is snake games I'm going
to create few new files that is called
index
.html
and here
I'm going to create a new file name
called app
dot JS at the same time I'll be having
some of the CSS files if I need so I can
say app Dot CSS so total number of three
files I have it now let me close down
all the files whichever I have opened it
earlier
so
now that looks cleaner approach so this
is a snake game for us from where we
need to start and we have a index.html
file and here I will as you should
create
our basic HTML syntax and here I would
like to include
our script tag
the script
SRC equal to
app.js
that's it and now going forward we will
start developing our next implementation
of snaking
now inside my body tag I would like to
have some
basic property called speed
okay and later on I'll be taking the
input from the client so we are saying
input type equal to
so here we can justify the speed and we
can give ID equal to
game speed
and followed by value
equal to we can give the value equal to
5 initial value and Min equal to
1 that is the minimum value and Max
equal to 9 that is the maximum and
minimum value we can offer beyond that I
won't allow the users to go and step
that means the increment value that is
1.
well that is the input type and now
another input we are taking input
type equal to
button and value
equal to
start
and then ID equal to
game start
okay so we're giving this values
after that
I can give some bricks
so two bricks we're giving it and start
working with a div diagonal
and in this Dev tag I'll be using the
canvas
it is a HTML5 feature
we use canvas
and I just give ID equal to
game
area
there's a canvas and after this canvas
we will
the div tag is closed here after div tag
I can use another Dev tag
div here I can say class equal to
I may not have any class written but I
can say
class equal to relative so later on if I
want to apply any CSS style I can
certainly apply
and after that I can offer the images
okay if I may not have any images right
now so I just leave this image blank
right now
okay and this is script SRC I'll load it
only before my body tag had closed it's
always a good practice to keeping this
script tag on a bottom of the body tag
always designed for good practice
now this is almost ready for me let me
check
okay so I can see values
now it will go maximum 9 that is how we
have given and minimum is one
start with the button which is not doing
anything but later on we can allow some
logic inside this
now we have to start working with our
main JavaScript tag this is my app.js
and here onwards we will use
some of the properties okay which I want
to initialize it so we are saying or
game start
equal to none
initialize second game speed
equal to
none
next game area
equal to
null
Game Area context
equal to none
then give area width
Game Area width
equal to
0 that is in integer value Game Area
height
game area
equal to 0 again
then solve it
solve it equal to 0
play score
equal to 0 again
next snake
equal to null
next is snake food
next snake Direction
equal to null
snake speed or a second set speed size
speed size
equal to zero
next we have a timer
equal to
so these number of properties we've
initialized
okay now after that we will be writing a
function by saying function
name is called initialize
okay and here initialized we would like
to use some of the properties first we
are saying game start equal to
document Dot
get element by ID here I can give the
value called hash
game start let me put it in double
quotes
okay
start
now game speed now these are all
basically the values are there game
start game speed these all values we
have to take it okay so we will be
seeing these values one by one so let me
set another one that is called game
speed
game speed equal to again
document Dot get element by ID now we
are passing the game speed View
game speed
now
here
once again I will take another point
game area
I say okay
game area here we have to give the value
called game area
okay so these values we have taken now
we'll be talking about called Game Area
context
give me the context equal to
game area
Dot
get context
get
and in this game context we will be
using what type of context we're using
2D
okay because I want to have the kind of
2D so this is how the kind of
environment we want to set next we talk
about Game Area width
equal to just initialize to 400
next
Game Area height
equal to 600
now sell it
we are initializing with 20.
next game area dot width
okay so Game Area Dot
width equal to
Game Area width
and then we Define km area dot height
Dot
equal to
the game area height
so these are the values we are
initializing this okay now after that we
have to start writing the logic here I'm
saying game start
game start dot now we have to line uh
which event you would like to take so I
will say on
click
on click so when I basically click what
should happen so on click equal to
function
so what you want to write it here I'm
saying this Dot
this dot disabled
equal to true
so I'm going to disable these values and
after that we want to call another
function inside this but which function
let's do that so here we are saying
function
start game start
okay and here in start game we want to
Define the initial score see the initial
score for the player will be certainly
zero so we say
player
score equal to zero
after that direction in which direction
you want the snake to move so we are
saying snake
Direction equal to right
in the right direction then speed size
the value of the variable which we've
defined so speed size equal to because
it will be accepting the value from the
text boxes or from the drop down so it
can certainly will be string type so we
have to use percent
so using this option called percent and
here we are using
game speed Dot
value
okay so we are using this value again
speed dot value now here we would like
to calculate certain things
what those are first we are saying if
okay what if condition
uh see this function we are writing
called start game
because there are certain things which
you need to make it so like that you
have to Define it so function initialize
we have started
okay and then after that we have written
on click within this
so this is what the on click we had and
there onwards we have to finish this
point
and after that we've started start game
and now we'll be writing the logic for
this so here we are saying if we think
speed size
missing equal to 9.
we basically initialize to what nine
here we say else if
speed size
is
we say speed size
sorry
speed size equal to one that means if it
is less than 0 I will be making it
minimum to one if it is greater than 9
I'll be making it to 9 maximum and
that's it
okay so after this else if condition is
getting closed we are seeing speed size
equal to 1 so here we just say snake
snake equal to
array so that is my array for me and
after that we are saying snake
dot push
because it needs to move ahead and here
we'll be pushing it towards by saying X
position 0 and
then the Y
and here the Y value will be what
sell bit that means how far it can go so
it'll go within the width of this
application
okay so that's how exactly we would like
to make it
okay so here we have a call Salvage we
have given here after that what we have
to do is
we have to Define our own function
called
clear interval and this clear interval
will perform any logic whichever I would
like to make it
okay so here after the snake dot push
value has been given here I will be
creating one more function here that's
known as called
uh create food okay so here we're saying
create
food
so create food will be the function for
me now you might be thinking where this
function is but this one should be
declared soon within your application
but here first we are saying the
function called clear interval
clear interval with a timer
[Music]
we'll be passing it
and after that this clear interval will
be same timer
equal to
set interval
with this we are saying create game area
create
now here in our application whatever the
value we are giving it that we need to
basically implement we are giving this
called create food is a function we are
calling after that we are calling this
clear interval clear interval will be
just like in a typical function which is
there using this option called create
game area
so
this will be available to me on which
the value will be taken that
okay and then we will be telling you how
you can call this function create food
and how to create it first well so we
are talking about a functionality call
create game interval so this create game
timer is the one which we have to create
it by our own so this function which we
are passing it after the same set
interval this function is not it there
so we have to basically go back and
create this function within my
application
fine so what we will do is just
particular one we will try to comment it
for a time being okay so here we have a
call what create interval in this
created level will be
passing any parameters which we are
password about as a timer here and here
we are calling this called create food
so here after that we'll be calling this
function called create food so let's go
and say
function create food
and this function create food let's go
and write the logic here
and what logic we want to write it in a
great food we say snake food
snake food equal to
and here in our curly basis we use two
Direction X and Y
we say in X we say
math Dot
round
and insert this we say
math
Dot
random
after this method random function we
have to just take this calculation and
check the another parameter called Game
Area width
game
area width minus
subject the one which you are causing it
and here after that we'll be performing
the calculation by saying
celebrate
okay so this is for our x coordinate
similar way we would like to use for my
y coordinate also
area
[Music]
Game Area height
but here rather than using width we'll
be using height
minus
solve it let me give some space
divided by cell width
okay so that's where exactly it's got
closed
okay now here our applications is now
ready by calling the function called
create four
like that we'll be going to create
another function called create game area
let me go and create all the functions
first so we are saying
function create game area
create game
area there's another function for me
after this create Game Area there will
be another function I'm going to create
it that is called control
function control
okay after that we'll gonna write one
more function called function
right School
there's another function available for
us control we have a call write score
there's another function which you're
going to write it down here that is
called function
write score is done now we say create
Square so to create
Square
is another function and finally we'll
have a call change direction
function change
change direction
so that's it these many functions we
wanted to create return here in our
system well we know it very well that we
have taken this called create food
create food function is already ready
now now we're going to talk about our
next function called create gain area
and in this create game area we are
defining two locations of our X
Direction and Y interactions we said
a snake
x equal to
snake the position we are taking is
called zero and we say dot X
for the X Direction
we are saying VAR
snake
y equal to
snake position we are taking once again
zero
and Dot okay so two directions we have
taken X Direction and Y Direction
now here we are starting
again
area context Dot
filter unit variable it is a property
fill style equal to which color you want
to fill this up
so I'm saying hash white color
okay and then we are using this game
area context again
dot fill react
fill react
so keep the position values I'm saying 0
comma zero comma Game Area width
game area with comma
Game Area height
so we are basically filling the values
with color we want to use it called
stock style let me take this game area
context again
Dot
stock Style
stroke Style
equal to now we give the another color
here by saying hash
okay and then the next option called
same give me the context dot stroke
react
stroke
react and here we pass the values again
0 comma zero comma Game Area width
comma
again
area
height
so we are passing those values like that
and now after this we have to write a
logic of the directions now see the when
you talk about snake game it move left
right and Center up and down so now in
this case we have to increment the
situations accordingly so we say if
the snake Direction
if the stick Direction
right
then we say snake
X
Plus
now
else if
same
let's copy this
snake Direction
left
then what should happen here we say
snake
X
minus minus
okay so we are taking like that let me
copy this again
now here
here we're talking about left right we
sit down
so in this case we say snake
why
plus plus
and in this case
if it is up
let me see it's name
y minus
so these conditions we are taking it now
now here after this SF condition we
would like to take another if condition
now here in my if condition we are
using some more lengthy statements
what's that we say if snake X
if snakes X
minus 1
or
snake X
double equal to
Game Area width which we have taken
divided by
solve it
okay or
we are taking this condition called The
Snake y
snake y double equal to
minus 1
okay so we're giving this call minus one
or
snake y
stick y equal to
okay area height
to serve it
or
here we will take the another condition
here
yeah we will take the another condition
here call
we will have another function called
control
which we have
created it sometime back and inside is
control
it will take some parameters so what of
parameters we can pass and we can say
a snake X
comma
snake y
third parameter will be
mistake
so this would be my another function
okay so here we are passing the
conditions just like that
okay now here
this is availability is a parenthesis
and here
we're writing the situation for right
score
which is so far the function is only
created not described more so we're
writing the right score the score will
be written here and here is a clear
interval
because the typer will be stopped
okay I'm using game start
Dot
disabled
equal to
thoughts
and after that return
that's it so this is the logic for we
have written for this particular example
now we can use another if more
conditions here just to check the
behavior of my code if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
well here we have finished till this
game start dot disabled equal to false
and we returned now going forward after
this return
we would like to have another condition
for the snake X so we say if
snake X
snake X double equal to
snake food
dot X
okay let's make photex temperature
snake why
double equal to snake
food dot y
then in this case I will say VAR new
head
bar new head sorry
new hit equal to here
X colon
snake X
foreign
these options we are taking it
now after that we are using this option
called play score
plus equal to
speed size
and then we are calling
create food method again
and here after that we're using the else
condition
and in this else condition we are saying
VAR
new head
equal to
snake
dot or
okay and we are saying new head
dot X
equal to snake X
and new head
dot y equal to
snake y
so these variables basically associating
with your heads and after that we are
saying snake
Dot unshift
and shift
snake Dot unshift and here we are
passing this option called new head
thank you
that's it and after that we'll be
starting with our for Loop by saying for
VAR equal to y
I equal to 0
then I is less than
a snake Dot
length
and
snake dot length and once I
plus plus
okay later on we just use the optional
call
create
square and in discrete Square we are
passing
snake
snake position
I
Dot
X
comma same
snake
dot y
that's it so it's getting closed here
and after that we are calling the same
option with this snake food let me copy
this again
and here rather than using this we can
just make food protects
and it's like food.y
okay so now this values has been added
into my code now if we start working
with your control
needs to take three parameters x y and
the array so we are passing this option
called control and in this control we
are taking X
comma y comma
array
three parameters we are taking it later
on we are using this option called for
bar I equal to 0
I is listed
array Dot
length and I plus plus and after that
we'll be using this option called if
condition and here we say
array
I which value you're passing dot X
double equal to
X amp percent time percent
here we say array
with the position called I
and in this we are saying dot Y and this
position we are checking for
the Y condition
for the Y condition so it Returns what
true
return
the condition
okay that is for if condition else
return one
false
you know
that's it now we are talking about this
option you call write score this right
score we have to use the game media
context
game
area context Dot
font
equal to here we'll be passing the
situation using 50 pixels
50 pixels and then
since iPhone
service
after that we are using call km context
again let me copy this
take it again called Game Area context
Dot
fifth style equal to here I'll be using
another color now so we say hash
okay now after that we are saying once
again the game area context Dot
fill text
here we are saying
score
colon
and here we say Plus
player score whatever it is with Game
Area width
Game Area width
slash two
minus
100.
and then again
area width
slash two so this is great exactly the
right score where the data will be
actually written
okay next will be having this option
called create square and this great
Square it takes two parameters one we're
talking about column X second is taking
Y and now here we're using this game
ideally context
same
Dot
film style equal to let me give the
color
after this we are using call same query
and text
game media text Dot
foreign
here using X
multiplied by
solve it comma y
Salvage comma
solve it comma
solve it
this is what my grade square is now we
are left with only one option that is
known for change direction
it's time to figure out this last
function called change direction
which takes one parameter called e
typically we talk about for
parameters now here we are passing this
option called War keys
equal to e Dot
and later on we want to say if
keys
equal to
okay
amp percent ampersand
snake Direction
equal to
up
okay so here we say
snake Direction equal to
so we're changing the directions here
okay now let me try to copy this
[Music]
and here we use elseif
foreign
[Music]
okay
so here we took this 30 40 and here we
say 39
and followed by 38
followed by 27.
29 28 37 and here we say up let's change
to what
left
down
right
here we say
up
left
the three options we have changed and
last but not least here I'll just use
window Dot
on key down equal to
change directions
and
window
dot on load
okay equal to
initialaries that's how exactly we want
to use now and this function what we
have defined in initialize
okay so in this initialize
we are having this game start dot on
click in and all so you have a called
start game now so just start game will
be calling it here
okay so let's start
we have a cold snake we were called
snake dot push
and after that we are calling this
function called what create food
clear interval and here we say driver
equal to here set clear interval and
here
change
game area
slash
speed size
let's say you want to use it okay
everyone so our code is almost ready so
we have this complete JavaScript code
ready with me now it's time to basically
use within my HTML just to check how it
may behave so in my HTML page I have
written this normal speed number
game speed value button start we will
call game start after that we have a
call canvas where we print ID code to
call Game Area Dev class equal to
relative and
that's it and here we have a call script
Sr secret to app.js
so that's it what we have written now
finally we would like to see how it may
look if I try to use in my browser let
me try to refresh
okay I really do not see any changes in
my code
okay uh despite I'm having this because
the CSS content is actually missing
okay because they're only my code really
look better because if there is no CSS
it won't really make good towards my
application
okay and I also want to have certain
images but those images we will take it
a little later on let me go back and try
to bring CSS into this picture now so
first of all
have this index.html file with me and
here I want to use CSS so inside my head
tag we want to use
link Ariel
equal to
style sheet
okay Enter
equal to
app
dot CSS
okay now here
in my CSS we want to offer certain
details what those details I want to
start working with I will start with my
body part
body
so we want to offer the font family
so
one family maybe a little bit later on I
can use it first I want to use margin
margin 20 pixels
Auto
later text
align
Center
next font size
font size 150 pixels also 150 percent
and here we want to say background
background image since I do not have an
image so I will just leave it as a blank
okay so just otherwise I have to say URL
and insert this URL
to give some values but I leave it as a
blank because I do not have any image I
will say background color
this background color I can just use
white
after that height
I can just say 800 pixels
after that background position
background position I want to use Center
then background repeat
background repeat I want no repeat
foreign size
okay let's see if there is an effect in
my
okay I see it's now in the middle
better now inputs canvas we have to
basically take that here we should talk
about call input
okay in this input I say font size
font size may be optional I can make it
but let me say font size 100
percent
then text align
Center
then padding
I want to say 5 pixels
and
seven pixels
okay looks better now
well here after that I can use canvas
in this canvas
I want to see the background color
I just say white
after that border radius
for the radius I can say 20 pixels
then
Shadow if I want to use it
so I just say box shadow
box Shadow I can say three pixels
5 pixels
and 6 pixels
and the color is
check
awesome so I can see here uh
the
logic is there so Shadow you can easily
see how it is been using and that's it
and this div
I can say div Dot
relative
position
absolute
top
here I'm saying using 760 pixels
left
120 pixels
that's it
so this is where exactly a program now
when I say start
okay so there may be some error here
the thing cannot set a property or call
on click
null so this we can just check this into
this
game start dot on click
let's check
anyways we just try to fix that issue in
a while but anyways we have our created
CSS and now going forward we'll be
implementing rest of the logic within my
code okay everyone so we have changed
some names here because there was some
value was mismatched so we have
basically changed those values with your
properties and now when I try to
relaunch my application
by uh
this
index.html file
so now in my index.html file when I try
to add
so it's just as usual same let me say
start and here you can see game start
when I go up you see like it's starting
right now
okay isn't this an amazing game right
now friends
okay that is the same game what you used
to play it earlier okay where you can
just change the direction go up and you
can see the score Channel being placed
here
that's it so this is where exactly the
look and feel of your game has been
taken
and you can just increase the speed
suppose if you just put a value called
what zero by default set
whatever value you want to take it with
a start now you can see
based on that the speed can be justified
and the example can be developed
okay you can see the start button is
disabled because right now the user is
still going on unless the user game is
finished this one is not going to work
right so like that you can see that
automatically this will be position
there's no it's called food that is how
we have used it by example on called
app.js you can see we are using this
example name called food create food you
can create food of the specific interval
time this will be automatically created
and the snake will eat and increase the
size of the code
okay that's it and now the CSS has been
given if you want to add certain image
certainly you can add it otherwise this
is the first scheme which we can see how
it is running and giving you the better
example
and with that we've come to the end of
this video I hope you had fun building
these applications
if you have any doubts or Paris let us
know in the comment section below thank
you for watching keep learning and stay
tuned for more from Simply on